[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल एक बार सब
लोग मुझे ये कंफर्म कर दीजिए सबको मेरी
आवाज आ रही है या नहीं आ रही है प्लीज चैट
में यस या नो बता
दीजिए
यस थैंक यू तो वेलकम टू डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी
य चैनल और आज हम डे सिक्स क्लास के साथ आए
हैं कुछ और नया टॉपिक लेके कुछ और नई
चीजें करने के लिए काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
धीरे-धीरे हम इंटरेस्ट के साथ आगे बढ़ रहे
हैं तो पहले एक चीज मुझे ये बताइए कितने
लोग ऐसे जो आज फर्स्ट टाइम फर्स्ट डे है
क्लास का लाइव क्लास
में कितने लोग हैं टोटल सेवन है लाइव लाइव
में से सेवन में से एक दो हमारा हो सकता
है तो बाकी यह बताइए कि कितने लोग हैं
जिसका आज फर्स्ट डे है आज की क्लास में
लाइव में फर्स्ट
डे
बताइए कोई है ऐसा
नाम क्या फैक्ट नंबर वन पहली बात तो रियल
नाम से कोई नहीं
है ओके किंग भी फर्स्ट डे है फैक्ट नंबर
वन भी फर्स्ट डे
है क्या अगर आप लोगों को पहले से आता है
तो कोई इशू नहीं है आप कंटिन्यू कर सकते
हैं आपको अगर आईडिया है थोड़ा बहुत भी की
बेस के बारे में क्या चीजें होती है बट एक
और चीज बताऊंगा भले ही आपको पहले से ही
आता हो लेकिन अगर जो हमने स्टार्ट किया था
डे थ्री से जो हमने स्टार्ट किया था वह
सबके लिए ही नया है बिल्कुल जिसने मास्टर
लेवल का या एक्सपीरियंस लिया हुआ है या
इंडस्ट्री में थोड़ा बहुत काम किया अगर
ऐसा कोई इंसान है तो उसको पता होगा वो
चीजें कैसे काम करती हैं अदर वाइज आई डोंट
नो कि उसको भी इतना आईडिया होगा बट कह
सकता हूं उनको आईडिया होगा तो अगर बिल्कुल
ही नया है किसको कोई भी आईडिया नहीं है
इसके बारे में तो प् प्लीज मैं ये बोलूंगा
कि आप साथ के साथ हमारी लाइव क्लास देखते
रहिए आपको चीजें समझ में आएंगी लाइव क्लास
स्किप करने की जरूरत नहीं है बट जैसे ही
आपको टाइम मिलता है तो प्रीवियस अभी तक
पांच ही क्लास हुई है और ज्यादा बड़ी बड़ी
क्लास नहीं है छोटी-छोटी क्लास है 30 टू
35 मिनट का ही कंटेंट रहता है उसके बीच
में फिर हम डाउट ले लेते हैं स्टार्टिंग
कुछ ऐसे ही हम आपको थोड़ा मोटिवेट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं तो वो चीजें हैं तो जाइए
और वन बाय वन उनको देखिए ओके तो आपको बहुत
कुछ सीखने का मिलेगा और धीरे-धीरे हम क्या
है कि अपनी जनरी को काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
बनाते जाएंगे धीरे-धीरे हम कमांड के साथ
आएंगे धीरे धीरे प्रोजेक्ट के साथ आएंगे
धीरे धीरे हम ग्रुप में आपसे क्वेश्चन
आंसर भी कर रहे हैं और मुझे यह चीज पता
चली कि जो लोग क्या है कि देखते नहीं है
उससे आईडिया मिल ग्रुप में यह आईडिया मुझे
मिल गया कि टेलीग्राम ग्रुप में कि वो सच
में ही नहीं देखते और उन्हें कोई आईडिया
नहीं है बस आके व ग्रुप में सब यह बोल
देंगे कि ये वो ये वो ये वो बट आई डोंट नो
कि उन्हें कुछ आता भी नहीं है और फिर
बकवास कितनी भी करवा लो सर आई एम सॉरी फॉर
दैट ये लैंग्वेज यूज करने के लिए बट सच
यही है मैंने देखा कितने लोग वहां कितने
आंसर कर पाते हैं बेसिक क्वेश्चंस है उनका
भी आंसर व लोग कर नहीं
पाते तो हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं आज के सेशन
में और जो आज नए हैं उनके लिए यह है कि
प्लीज गो टू आवर अ लिंक नीचे जाइए मोड में
जाइए
आपको जो लास्ट सेशन मैंने पढ़ाया था स्टेप
थ्री एक्सपेंशन के बारे में कि जब
टोकेनाइजेशन कंप्लीट हो जाता है तो जो
वर्ड्स टोकना स्टेप के बाद जो वर्ड्स होते
हैं वर्ड्स के ऊपर क्या है एक्सपेंशस काम
करते हैं फोर स्टेजेस होती है एक्सपेंशन
की ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
टिल डेट एक्सपेंशन स्टेज थ्री होती है
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग स्टेज फोर होती है
ग्लोबिंग अब ये भी बताया था इसमें दो
इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट है कि फर्स्ट थिंग यू
नीड टू नो एक्सपेंशन इन अर् स्टेस आर
परफॉर्म फर्स्ट जो सबसे पहले आएगा वो सबसे
पहले परफॉर्म किया जाएगा लेकिन सेकंड नोट
मैंने आपको यह बताया था कि जो स्टेज ट परर
है वो सभी के सभी क्या है उनकी प्रायोरिटी
सेम है तो वो एक ऑर्डर में परफॉर्म करेंगे
क्योंकि जो भी आपकी कमांड होती है वो क्या
करती है आपकी लेफ्ट टू राइट ही हमेशा
परफॉर्म की जाती है लेफ्ट टू राइट में जो
स्टेज टू वाली है उसमें जो पहले आएगा
पैरामीटर अर्थमेटिक कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन जो
पहले आएगा उसको परफॉर्म किया जाएगा सिंपली
ये दो नोट्स आपको ध्यान रखने की जरती है
आज जो मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं मैं स्टेप
फोर प जा जाने वाला नहीं जो स्टेप फोर
हमारा एक और स्टेप फोर रीडायरेक्शन है और
स्टेप फाइव हमारा जो नेस्ट कोट रिमूवल और
स्टेप फाइव है हमारे डायरेक्शन उसपे जाने
वाला नू मैं उससे पहले मैं इन स्टेज वन
स्टेज टू स्टेज थ्री स्टेज फोर इनके बारे
में पढ़ाऊंगा तो आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक
रहेगा वो है आपका पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन जो
आपको दिख रहा है ये पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन के
बारे में पढ़ाने वाला हूं काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग है उसके बाद अर्थमेटिक कमांड
टिल डेट वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग ग्लोबिंग और
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन इनके बारे में बताऊंगा
देन उसके बाद हम स्टेप फोर प जाएंगे लेकिन
ये क्या है थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकली भी है और
इंटरेस्टिंग भी है और कुछ चीजें बहुत
अच्छी अच्छी चीजें आपको सीखने के लिए तो
मैं मिनट म
टाइम एक
मिनट गिव मी गिव मी टाइम
[संगीत]
यस
चलो तो जो हमारा डे सिक्स
है आज जो हमारा है डे
सिक्स ओके डे सि में आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
वह है आपका पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं
आपका जो टॉपिक आज का रहेगा
आपका यह होता क्या इसके बारे में पढ़ने
वाले डोंट वरी परा डिटेल में
बताऊंगा यह चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं किसी
को समझ में नहीं आ सबको समझ में आएगा इट
माय पर्सनल
गारंटी
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन के बारे में बताने
वाला चलो देखो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन समझने
से पहले आपको एक चीज का पता होना चाहिए व
क्या होता है वेरिएबल एक टॉपिक है वेरिएबल
इसके बारे में आपको पता होना चाहिए आर आई
ए बी ए वेरिएबल जब तक आपको नहीं पता तब तक
आपको पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन समझ में नहीं
आएगा अब ये वेरिएबल क्या होता है सबसे
पहले हम य चीज तो सबसे पहले जो सामने वेबल
समझने से पहले सबसे पहले सवाल होगा ट इ
पैरामीटर पैरामीटर क्या होता है य
पैरामीटर होता क्या किस बीमारी का नाम किस
बला का नाम है पैरामीटर देखो पैरामीटर
क्या होता है
ए
पैरामीटर इ एनी एंटिटी एनटी एंटिटी
ट स्टोर्स
वैल्यूज एक कोई भी ऐसी एंटिटी हो सकती है
जो वैल्यू को स्टोर करती है उसको हम बोलते
हैं पैरामीटर ओके जो सेल पैरामीटर्स होते
हैं जो सेल पैरामीटर्स होते हैं उनका यूज
हम वैल्यू को स्टोर करने के लिए वैल्यू या
डाटा बोल सकते हैं डाटा को स्टोर करने के
लिए और उसके बाद एक बार स्टोर करने के बाद
अपनी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर
रेफरेंस करने के लिए हम उनका यूज करते हैं
अगेन मैं बता देता हूं जो सेल पैरामीटर्स
है उनका हम यूज करते हैं अपने डाटा को
स्टोर करने के लिए और स्टोर करने के बाद
अपने स्क्रिप्ट में यूज करने के लिए हम
क्या करते हैं उस डाटा को रेफर करते हैं
तो रेफर करने के लिए हम सेल पैरामीटर का
यूज करते हैं बेसिकली दे थ्री टाइप्स ऑफ
सेल
पैरामीटर देयर
आर
ी टाइप्स ऑफ सेल
पैरामीटर्स तीन टाइप के होते है सेल
पैरामीटर्स कौन-कौन सा पहले बताता हूं
आपको फर्स्ट टाइप होता है जो वो होता आपका
वेरिएबल होता है जो सेकंड होता है आपका व
होता है आपका पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर पोजीशनल पैरामीटर पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर पोजीशनल पैरामीटर अब वेरिएबल की
थ स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक हो ग सरीट नेक्स्ट
थर्ड नंबर होता स्पेशल
पैरामीटर स्पेशल
पैरामीटर
य तीन टाइप के आपके सेल पैरामीटर होते अब
वेरिएबल क्या
है मोस्ट कॉमनली यूज पैरामीटर ओके पोशन
पैरामीटर बता स्पेल पैरामीटर डोंट वरी
लेकिन अब बात करते हैं वेरिएबल कीय
वेरिएबल होता क्या है जिसकी मैं बात करने
वाला हूं यह वेरिएबल होता क्या
है इसको एक काम करते हैं यहां से यह
वेरिएबल होता क्या है चलो बात
करते
क्याय वट इज
वेरिएबल व्ट इज ए
वेरिएबल य वेरिएबल होता
क्या वेरिएबल हर बार स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक हो
है वेरि
बल्स आर
पैरामीटर्स वेरिएबल क्या है पैरामीटर्स
हैं वूज वैल्यू वज
वैल्यू यू
कैन मैनुअली
चेंज मैनुअली
चेंज बेसिकली क्या है पैरामीटर्स का आपको
मालूम हो गया पैरामीटर्स क्या है
पैरामीटर्स क्या है एक एंटिटी है जो
वैल्यू को स्टोर करती है वेरिएबल क्या है
वेरिएबल वह पैरामीटर्स है जो वैल्यू को अ
जो
वेरिएबल वो पैरामीटर्स है जिनकी वैल्यू को
हम मैनली चेंज कर सकते हैं आई होप आपको
समझ में आया ट वेरिएबल आप लोग के लिए क्या
करता हू हाईलाइट कर देता हूं और एक अलग
कलर में कर देता हूं आपको क्लियर ओके य
वेरिएबल समझ में आ गया अब इससे पहले अगर
आपने वेरिएबल के बारे में कभी नहीं भी
सुना है या कहीं पर पढ़ा भी नहीं है डोंट
वरी लेट्स टेक एन एग्जांपल सबसे पहले
एग्जांपल लेते हैं देखो आप इमेजिन करो कि
हमारे जो प्रोग्राम छोटे छोटे बॉक्सेस है
छोटे छोटे बॉक्सेस है जिनको हम यूज कर रहे
हैं और हर एक बॉक्स का एक नाम है और उस
बॉक्स के अंदर हम कोई ना कोई वैल्यू रख
रहे हैं कोई ना कोई डाटा रख रहे फॉर एपल
मैं आपको शो कर देखि ओके ये रहा नो नो य
ये क्या है हमारे प्रोग्राम में क्या है
छोटे छोटे बॉक्सेस है छोटे छोटे बॉक्स मैं
बॉक्स लेलेता हूं ये रहा लो ओके अब ये
मेरा क्या है बॉक्स है इसका भी एक नाम है
इसका कोई कुछ भी नाम हो सकता है फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं इसका नाम ले दिया मैंने
बॉक्स का
नाम थोड़ा वैल्यू कम होए बॉक्स का नाम
लिखा मैंने स्टूडेंट एस टी यू डी ई एन टी
स्टूडेंट इस बॉक्स का नाम क्या है
स्टूडेंट है तो इसको हम क्या क्या बोल
सकते हैं कि वेरिएबल बोल सकते हैं हम इस
बॉक्स को क्या बोल सकते हैं वेरिएबल अब ये
छोटे छोटे बहुत सारे बॉक्सेस है अब मैं
बात करता हूं इस बॉक्स के अंदर क्या है
हमने डाटा रखा हुआ है तो जब मैं ऐसा बोलता
हूं कि मैं मैं एक बार एरो आपको शो कर
देता हूं ये रहा एक एरो है यह रहा
नेक्स्ट य
रहा य रहा अब य पर क्या है य डाटा
स्टूडेंट है स्टूडेंट के अर हम नाम रखने
वाले नाम रखते तो य कंट्रोल सी और
कंट्रोल यह आपका
डटा टा अभी डटा आपका य पर है अब क्या है
आप बॉक्स यूज कर रहे हो तो एक बार डटा
क्या ध्यान से देखना कि जब मैं बोलता हूं
कि मैं य पर एक चीज बोल देता हूं
य
जब मैं बोलता
हूं
न
यू असाइन
ए वैल्यू टू ए
वेरिएबल वल टू ए
वेरिएबल जब हम ऐसा बोलते हैं इसका सिंपली
मतलब समझना टू ए
वेरिएबल इट इसका मतलब क्या है न यू असाइन
वैल्यू टू ए वेरिएबल इट
मींस इट
मींस
यू
आर यू आर
पुटिंग
डाटा इनटू द बॉक्स इनटू द बॉक्स
सिंपली जब भी मैं इसको बोल ये रहा ये रहा
व्हेन यू असाइन ए वैल्यू टू वेरिएबल जब आप
अपने वेरिएबल को जब भी वैल्यू असाइन करोगे
उसका मतलब समझिए कि आप डाटा को बॉक्स केर
पुट कर रहे हो क्योंकि बॉक्स आपका वो
वेरिएबल है सिली ऐसे जब मैंने बोला तो डटा
वैल्यू य पर आया डटा अब आपका डटा इधर है
नेक्स्ट जब हम बोलते हैं इसको कंट्रोल
सी कंट्रोल
ब
न
यू
वन
रेफर
और न यू रेफरेंस ए वेरिएबल रेफरेंस
ए रेफरेंस ए
वेरिएबल इट मींस इट
मींस
यू यू
गेट द डाटा बैक आउट आउट ओके इसका मतलब
सिंपली ये है जब आपको बोला जाता है आपका
डाटा ये रहा इधर फॉर एग्जांपल जब आपको
बोला जाता कि जब आप किसी वेरिएबल को
वैल्यू असाइन कर इसका मतलब क्या है ये
डाटा को क्या कर असाइन कर रहे हो बॉक्स के
अंदर रख रहे हो जब आपको बोल कि यर रे
रेफरेंस वेरिएबल आप किसी वेरिएबल को क्या
कर रहे हो रेफर कर रहे हो इसका मतलब क्या
है कि ये डाटा को क्या कर रहे हो आप बॉक्स
से बाहर निकाल रहे हो और इसको यूज कर रहे
हो ये है बिल्कुल ही लेमन भाषा में बहुत
ही आसान भाषा में आपका एग्जांपल मैं
कंट्रोल सी इधर भी रख देता हूं ब और
कंट्रोल v यह रहा
समझे अब आपको शायद समझ में अच्छे से आ रहा
होगा डाटा कैसे है सिंपली मतलब यह है अगर
मैं इसको और भी अच्छे से सम
एक कंट्रोल
जड रुक
जा सिंपली यह
रहा येय बोल
सकता सिंपली मतलब य है जब इसको उसके बाद
अगर मैं इसको बाद क्या कर रहा हूं
रेफरेंस यह रहा सिंपली य है इसका मतलब
उसके बाद मैं क्या आउट कर रहा हूं अब आपको
अच्छे से बिल्कुल ही क्लियर हो गया होगा
कि वेरिएबल होता क्या है आपको समझ में आया
अ जो वेरिएबल है दो टाइप के होते
वेरिएबल भी होते आपके यह भी दो टाइप्स के
होते हैं वेरिएबल आपके दो टाइप के होते
हैं देर
आर
टू टाइप्स ऑफ वेरिएबल मैं य पर उसकी बात
कर रहा हूं टू बस की
टू टाइप्स ऑफ वेरिएबल हर
प्रोग्राम ू टाइप्स ऑफ वेरिएबल कौन से
होते हैं आपको बताता आपको हाट कर देता हूं
बोल्ट ये
रहा दो टाइप कौन-कौन से होते हैं मैं आपको
बताता
हूं पहले जो टाइप्स होती है उसको हम बोलते
हैं सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल
सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं वेरिएबल
सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल
या मैं क्या बोल सकता हूं एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल ए एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल बबल एमेंट ल आई थ स्पल राइट है
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल ओके एक तो य बोल सकते
हैं
सिंपली मैं हाईलाइट नहीं करना चाता नहीं
करना चाहता फिर
भी ल नेक्स्ट जो आपका सेकंड
है
एवरी टाइम आ फिलिंग दिस
प्रॉब्लम सेकंड आपका होता है व यूजर
डिफाइंड
यूजर र डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल सेकंड आपका टाइप होता है व य
डिफाइंड वेरिएबल होता है य डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल अब सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं
यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल के बारे में अब यूजर
डिफा वेबल कौन से होते हैं यूजर डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल व होते हैं जो किसी भी यूजर के
द्वारा क्रिएट किए जाते हैं किसी भी यूजर
के द्वारा कट जाते उसको बोलते हैं हम यूजर
डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल हाउ टू क्रिएट वेरिएबल अब बात
करते हैं हम हाउ
टू क्रिएट
वेरिएबल हम वेरिएबल को कैसे क्रिएट करते
हैं इसको सिंटेक्स होता है देखो सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है उ सिंटेक्स में आपको
बताता हं य पर सिंपली आपको क्या करना
है वेरिएबल अंडर नेम वेरिएबल नेम उसके बाद
इक्वल साइन देन उसके बाद क्या वैल्यू उसके
बाद वैल्यू यह इसका
सिंटेक्स यहां पर हमें एक चीज को ध्यान
में रखना है कि जब भी हम कोई भी वेरिएबल
क्रिएट करते हैं तो हम इक्वल साइन के साथ
कोई भी स्पेस यूज नहीं करते इक्वल साइन ना
तो इससे पहले ना इसके बाद हम कोई भी स्पेस
यहां पर हम क्या नहीं
करते यूज नहीं करते समझ में आया ये इसका
सिंटेक्स वेल क्रिएट करने का फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं कैसे क्रिएट कर सकता हूं वेरिएबल अब
मैंने लिखा यहां पर वेरिएबल का नाम में
फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने लिखा स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट नाम लिखा देन इक्वल साइन और
स्टूडेंट का नाम लिखा मैं नितेश ए आई टी
एस नितेश ओके सिंपली ये स्टडेंट
नितेश ये समझ में आ गया होगा तो इस तरीके
से आप किसी भी वेरिएबल को डिफाइंड कर सकते
हैं अगर मुझे इसके इस वेरिएबल के डाटा को
देखना है तो मैं कैसे देखूंगा मैं अगर
रेफरेंस कैसे लूंगा जिसकी बात करर रेफर
गेट आउट उस डब्बे से ये डाटा को बाहर कैसे
निका लूंगा इसकी बात कर रहा हूं ना मैं
कैसे करूंगा तो जब मैं इसकी बात करता हूं
तो इसके लिए मैं क्या कर सिंपली मैं
सिंपली आपको एक प्रोफेशनल वे है प्रोफेशन
किको करूंगा देन उसके बाद मैं क्या लि
डॉलर सिंबल डॉलर सिंबल देन करली ओपन करली
बस देन वेरी बल का नाम स्टूडेंट उसके बाद
कली ब्रेसस क्लोज कली बस क्लो यह पूरा
प्रोफेशनल वे है और यह सही प्रॉपर तरीका
है लेकिन अगर आप ऐसा भी लिखोगे
एक डॉलर स्टूडेंट एस टी यू डीई एनटी अगर
ऐसा भी लिखोगे तब भी यह आपको आउटपुट शो
करेगा आपके स्टूडेंट वेरिएबल का लेकिन
क्या सही तरीका क्या है एकको डॉलर
स्टूडेंट जो कली ब्रेसस के अंदर ज वेरिएबल
का नाम देते हो सबसे सही तरीका यही है
सबसे सही तरीका यही है अब होता क्या मैं
आपको समझाता हूं य
पर जब भी आप ऐसा करते हो मैं आपको इस चीज
को समझाता हूं कि आपने स्टूडेंट का
स्टूडेंट है स्टूडेंट के लिए हमने क्या
नितेश नाम का एक वैल्यू डिफाइन की एक डाटा
डिफाइन किया इसके लिए डाटा रख दिया इस
बॉक्स के अंदर अब जब भी क्या करते हो आपने
एकको और कहीं पर आपने क्या किया डॉलर कर
लिए बेसेस और इसके अंदर आपने स्टूडेंट
लिखा अब ये क्या करता है यहां पर सेल क्या
करता है कि इसको ढूंढता है आपके मशीन में
कि स्टूडेंट नाम का वेरिएबल कहां पर है और
वहां से इस वैल्यू को
ढूंढेगा एक मिनट ये रहा स्टूडेंट नाम के
वेरिएबल को पैरामीटर को ढूंढता है वेरिएबल
को ढूंढता है और उसकी वैल्यू उसकी जो पूरी
वैल्यू क्या है नितेश है वैल्यू कितनी भी
बड़ी हो सकती है उस पूरी वैल्यू को लेके
आएगा और कैसे इस जो एक डॉलर स्टूडेंट है
एक डॉलर स्टूडेंट है एकको डॉलर स्टूडेंट
को कैसे रिप्लेस कर देगा एन आई टी ई एस एस
नितेश उसको कैसे रिप्लेस कर देगा नितेश अब
ये क्या बन जाएगा यहां पर एको डॉलर
स्टूडेंट की बज नितेश इसी चीज को हम बोलते
हैं पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन इसी चीज को क्या
बोलते हैं हम पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन जब भी आप
क्या करते हो कोई भी वेरिएबल डिफाइन करते
हो और वेरिएबल डिफाइन कर उसके अंदर एक
वैल्यू रखते हैं और और जब आप क्या करते हो
उस वैल्यू वैल्यू को रेफरेंस करते हो तो
सिंपली क्या होता है रेफरेंस करने के लिए
प्रोफेशनल वे ये है डॉलर कली बेसस
स्टूडेंट तो अब जो स्टूडेंट नाम के
पैरामीटर को ढूंढा जाता है इसकी वैल्यू को
उठा के यहां पर रखा जाता है इसकी जगह पर
रिप्लेस कर दिया जाता है और इस प्रोसेस को
हम बोलते हैं पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन इसको
बोलते हैं हम पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन यही है
वो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन जिसकी मैं बात कर
रहा हूं आपको अब मैं बात करूं तो ये है
आपका पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन इसी प्रोसेस को
हम पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन बोल सकते हैं वैसे
क भी छोड़ देते
चलो अरे
यार इसको बोलते हम पैरामीटर अब यह सब करने
का फायदा क्या है कि मुझे एक वेरिएबल
डिफाइन करना है वेरिएबल के अंदर हमें
वैल्यू डिफाइन करनी है यह सब करने का
फायदा क्या है सिंपली मैं यह भी कर सकता
था कि इस वैल्यू को डायरेक्ट अपनी कमांड
में रख दू और उसको यूज कर लू इससे इजी
तरीका तो कोई भी नहीं है ना इसका मेन
बेनिफिट तब हमें देखने को मिलता है जब हम
कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट बना रहे होते हैं या कोई
भी प्रोग्राम हम लिख रहे
हैं सिंपल कैसे इसका मतलब यह है कि हमें
इस वैल्यू को मल्टीपल प्लेसेस पर यूज करना
है फॉर एग्जांपल आपने कोई भी प्रोग्राम
बनाया कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट लिखी और आपको क्या
करना है कोई एक ऐसी वैल्यू जिसको मल्टीपल
प्लेसेस पर आपको यूज करना है ओके तो आपने
क्या किया जब आप प्रोग्राम लिख रहे तो
मल्टीपल प्लेसेस पर आप उस वैल्यू को लिख
सकते हो लेकिन अब आपके सामने एक सिचुएशन
खड़ी होगी सिचुएशन यह आई कि आपको उस
वैल्यू को रिप्लेस करना है तो आप ही बताइए
आपका प्रोग्राम 100 लाइन का है फॉर एपल
मिनिमम आपको बोल रहा 100 लाइन का
प्रोग्राम है क्या और 100 लाइन में आपका
25 टाइम्स इस य जो रिप्लेस करनी है वैल्यू
वो वहां पर रिपीटेड है क्या आप एक एक लाइन
पर जाओगे 25 टाइम्स उसको रिप्लेस करोगे नो
ना इसी सिचुएशन को क्या करने के लिए दूर
करने के लिए इसी स फाइट करने के लिए हमारा
जो कांसेप्ट है वेरिएबल का सिंपली क्या
करोगे आप अपनी मशीन अपने स्क्रिप्ट में
वेरिएबल को डिफाइन कर दोगे और वहां पर
जहां पर भी इसको यूज करना है उसको ऐसे यूज
कर लोगे उसके अंदर कमांड के अंदर और जब
आपके सामने ऐसी कोई नौबत आती भी है भले ही
आपका जो प्रोग्राम है थाउ लाइंस का हो या
2000 लाइंस का हो सिंपली आपको क्या करना
जहां पर वेरिएबल डिफाइंड है वहां पर उस
वैल्यू को रिप्लेस करना पूरे पूरे
प्रोग्राम में ऑटोमेटिक वो पूरी वैल्यू
रिप्लेस हो जाएगी देखा ना काम इजी हो जाता
है एक वेरिएबल की हेल्प से अब मैं एकको कि
अब मैं आपको दिखा भी दूंगा फॉर एग्जांपल
अगर आपको नहीं समझ में आया तो मैं आपको
दिखा भी देता हूं ये रहा एक बार मैं इसको
जूम कर देता ह
आपको तो लटकी आपको थोड़ा सा और क्
क्लेरिटी के साथ देखि य आज मैं अपने काली
की मशीन यूज कर रहा हूं फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने स्टूडेंट वेरिएबल की बात मैंने क्या
किया स्टूडेंट स्टूडेंट लिखा इक्वल साइन
उसके स्टूडेंट का नाम क्या लिखा था नि आई
टीई एसस निदेश किया हिट एंटर अब मैं क्या
करता हूं इसको मैंने क्या करना है रेफरेंस
करना एकको किया मैंने और
डॉलर डॉलर प्रॉपर तरीके से साथ दिखाता हूं
कली ब के अंदर मैं क्या लिखू स्टूडेंट एस
टी यू डी ई एनटी ये है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
ट एटर कर दिया क्या वैल्यू आई नितेश अगर
इसकी बजाय मैं ऐसा भी लिखता हूं
एकको डॉलर स्टूडेंट एसटी य डी ई एन टी काम
करेगा इट्स ओके बट क्या है कि सम टाइम जब
आप क्या जो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन आपको
बताऊंगा तो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन में कुछ
एडवांस फीचर्स है वो आप इसके साथ यूज नहीं
कर सकते सेकंड ऑप्शन के साथ फर्स्ट ऑप्शन
के साथ ही वो काम करते हैं इसलिए क्या है
कि राइट वे वही है आपका कलीस वाला तो इस
तरीके से काम कर रहा है इस वैल्यू को इसने
आपके आउटपुट में शो कर इस वैल्यू को कहीं
पर भी यूज कर सकते हैं सिंपली और ये
वैल्यू चेंजेबल है आप कुछ भी लिख सकते हो
तो आई आपको ये समझ में आ गया होगा समझ अब
ये एक चीज बताइए कि अगला सवाल ये होगा या
अगर आपके दिमाग में आया हो या ना आया हो
मैं आपको बताता हूं जो वैल्यू है आपकी जो
वेरिएबल की वैल्यू है क्या ये आपको लगता
है परमानेंट है क्या ये वैल्यू आपको लगता
है कि परमानेंट है या नहीं है बताइए नहीं
यह वैल्यू परमानेंट है टेंपररी है जैसे ही
आपको एक बार आप अपनी मशीन को लॉग इन लॉग
आउट करोगे तो ये जो स्टूडेंट नाम का जो
वेरिएबल है इसमें कोई भी वैल्यू नहीं होगी
ये क्या हट जाएगा अब परमानेंट करने के लिए
हमें इसकी फाइल प्रोफाइल फाइल इसकी जो
एंट्री होती है वो प्रोफाइल फाइल के अंदर
करनी पड़ती है ओके और प्रोफाइल फाइल मैंने
अपने कानेस की सीरीज में जहां तक मुझे याद
है मैंने पढ़ाया है ओके अगर नहीं पढ़ाया
होगा तो प्लीज मुझे ग्रुप में बता देना एक
स्पेशल वीडियो प्रोफाइल फाइल पे हम डिलीवर
कर देंगे न
ओके अब मैं और भी एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं कि
अब जो वेरिएबल है उसको क्रिएट करने के कुछ
रूल्स होते हैं सम रूल्स दे सम रूल्स ू
क्रिएट
वेरिएबल दे सम रूल्स टू क्रिएट वेरिएबल व
रूल्स कौन से हैं अरे
चलो
ओके
रूल्स
रूल्स कौन-कौन से है पहला रूल यह है
कि पहले रूल में आप क्या करते कोई भी
यू
कांट कांट
यूज
एनी
नंबर इन द
स्टार्टिंग स्टार्टिंग ऑफ वेरिएबल नेम
वेरिएबल नेम फर
एंपलॉयर
कैरेक्टर एस पई सी स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर इन द
स्टार्टिंग मतलब किसी भी वेबल लिखने के
लिए कोई भी स्पेशल कक्टर यूज नहीं कर सकते
स्टार्टिंग में और ना ही
कोई एसटी
ओके एस टी
ए
ओके
स्टार्टिंग स्टार्टिंग ऑफ
वेरिएबल
वेरिएबल ना ही आप ऐसे कर सकते थर्ड ऑप्शन
क्या है रा ना ही आप क्या है किसी
भी नंबर हो गया स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स हो गया
ना ही आप कोई भी बस हा दो रूल यह काफी
आपके लिए आपका फर एपल आपको दिखा रहा हूं
वेरिएबल यार बहुत परेशान कर दिया मेरा
टाइप ने अब फर एपल मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कि
मैं कभी ऐसे डिफाइन नहीं कर सकता की
रेट स्टूडेंट एसटी यूडी एनटी स्टूडेंट
इक्वल नितेश एंड आई टीई एस एच ऐसा मैं कभी
भी डिफाइन नहीं कर सकता अब देखो कमांड नॉट
फाउंड ये इसको और ही कुछ समझ रहा है मतलब
ये काम नहीं करेगा दूसरा मैंने क्या बोला
था किसी नंबर के साथ मैं लिगा फ एस टी यू
डीई एन टी स्टूडेंट इक्वल मैंने लिखा
नितेश ए आईडी नितेश फर एंडर किया ये भी
काम नहीं करेगा अगर मैं चाहू अंडरस्कोर के
साथ करना चाहूं कर सकता हूं क्या एस टी यू
डी ई एन टी इक्वल उसके बाद मैंने क्या
लिखा सचिन एस ए सी एच सचिन
हां आप ऐसे कर सकते हो अंडरस्कोर का यूज
कर सकते लेकिन कोई भी नंबर स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर और जब भी कोई आप वेरिएबल डिफाइन
करोगे कोई भी रिजर्व वर्ड रिजर्व वेरिएबल
भी आप यूज नहीं कर सकते रिजर्व वर्ड भी एज
पार्ट ऑफ वेरिएबल आप यूज नहीं कर सकते
रिजर्व वर्ड भी आप यूज नहीं कर सकते रिज
वर्ड पहले से ही होते हैं आपकी मशीन के
अंदर फॉर एपल एक हो को ही वेरिएबल डिफाइन
नहीं कर सकते आप ओके समझ में आया तो य भी
एक वेरिएबल हो गया य आपको रूल समझ में आ
गई होगी इसको दोबारा बताने की आपको जरूरत
नहीं होगी कि वेरिएबल कैसे आपको क्रिएट
करना है अब बात करते हैं हम सिस्टम
डिफाइंड वेरिएबल की बात करते हैं सिस्टम
डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल जिनको हम बोलते
हैं एनवायरमेंट रि यहां तक मुझे बताइए एक
बार चैट में यस या नो कि अभी तक जो मैंने
बताया यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल के बारे में
स्टिल यू हैव एनी डाउट रिलेटेड टू दिस
कांसेप्ट
टेल मी इन द चैट बॉक्स यस या
नो
बताइए
बताइए आपके कोर्सेस कहां मिलेंगे भैया य
पर मिलेंगे भैया जहां पर आप आए हो जहां पर
आप लाइव देख मेरे सारे कोर्सेस इसी पर अभी
तक पेड कोर्सेस ज्यादा पैसे हैं तो वैसे
दे दो यार कंट्रीब्यूट कर दो पेड कोर्सेस
जो मैं पेड कोर्सेस पढ़ाता हूं उतना डिटेल
ही पेड कोर्सेस
में अपनी प पर पढ़ाता हूं और इतना ही
डिटेल में यहां पर पढ़ाता हूं मेरे कंटेंट
डिलीवरी में कभी कोई चेंज नहीं
होते
ओके तो मैंने आप लोगों से एक सवाल पूछा था
उस सवाल का जवाब आप लोगों ने दिया
नहीं
बात करते हैं हम चलो सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल के बारे में सिस्टम
डिफाइंड
डिफाइन वेरिएबल जिसको य हम बोल सकते हैं
एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल
वेरिएबल एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल बोल सकते ओके
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल हम इसको बोल सकते हैं
सिस्टम डिफाइंड
रिबल
केके
गुड चलो
अब मैं लिख देता हूं पहले इसके लिए आपको
समझ में आएगा नहीं
वैसे
नेक्स एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल इज ए
डायनेमिक नेम वैल्यू डायनेमिक नेम
वैल्यू
च
मे
बी
यूज्ड
बाय वन और
मोर
प्रोग्राम्स वन और मोर
प्रोग्राम्स
वन और मोर प आर ओ
जी
प्रोग्राम्स
रनिंग सिंपली मतलब है अब ये आपको समझ में
नहीं आ रहा होगा मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करता
हूं क्या चीज है क्या मैं बताना चाहता हूं
मैं आपको क्या बताना चाहू व बताता हूं
देखो जब भी आप क्या करते हो अपने पीसी पर
काम करते हो तो वो आपके लिए एक एनवायरमेंट
होता है उसमें कुछ वेरिएबल होते हैं जो
हमने अपने पीसी में ग्लोबली
यूज कर सकते हैं और उन वेरिएबल को
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हैंडल करता
है अब हम कह सकते हैं काफी सारे वेरिएबल
पहले से ही सिस्टम में डिफाइन कर दिए जाते
हैं वो सारे वेरिएबल मिलकर एक एनवायरमेंट
क्रिएट करते हैं आपके लिए सिंपली य है कि
जब भी आप किसी भी पीसी में काम करते हो आप
कोई नया पीसी भी खरीदते हो या कोई भी मशीन
भी आप डाउनलोड करते हो कोई भी मशीन
इंस्टॉल करते हो कोई भी मशीन आप यूज करते
हो आपको वहां पर क्या है प्री डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल उसके अंदर सेट
किए हुए मिलते हैं और जैसे ही आप लॉगइन
करते हो तो उस आप ऑटोमेटिक काम करने लग
जाते हो तो वो क्या है वो आपका एक
एनवायरमेंट सेटअप है पहले से ही बहुत सारे
प्रोसेसेस क्या है एक से ज्यादा वेरिएबल
को यूज कर र होते है अपना काम करने के लिए
वहां आप लोग कुछ भी डिफाइन नहीं करते वो
है आपका एनवायरमेंट जो सिस्टम के द्वारा
डिफाइन किए हुए वेरिएबल हैं जो सिस्टम के
द्वारा डिफाइंड किए हुए वेरिएबल फॉर
एग्जांपल क्या है कि नक् में काफी सारे
यूजर्स है जब आप खुद के यूजर से लॉगइन
करते हैं तो आपको अपने यूजर से रिलेटेड
काफी सारी प्रॉपर्टी देखने को मिलती है जो
कि अपने आप में एक
एनवायरमेंट क्रिएट करता है और उस
एनवायरमेंट के अंदर हम काम करते हैं समझ
में आया इंडिविजुअल यूजर से लॉगिन करते हो
उसका अपना एक एनवायरमेंट है किसी कंपनी
में जाओगे तो आपको अपना यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
मिलेगा तो वहां पर क्या है कि आपका
एनवायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग आपकी परमिशन के
अनुसार सब कुछ क्या प्री डिफाइंड मिलेगा
और हो सकता है आपको वेलकम मैसेज मिले ड और
डोंट आपके सिस्टम की स्क्रीन पर पॉप अप
करे तो वो सारी चीजें कहां से आई आपने तो
डिफाइन नहीं किया ना तोव सारा काम क्या है
प्री डिफाइंड किया गया आपकी एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल के अंदर अब बात करता हूं कि कुछ
बहुत सारे कॉमनस वेरिएबल होते हैं जिन्हें
आपके बारे में पता होना चाहिए एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल ही होते हैं सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल जिनके बारे में आपको नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए अगर नहीं है तो अभी एक शायद गुरनीत
करके एक स्टूडेंट है जो टेलीग्राम उसका एक
डाउट था तो आज वो क्लियर हो जाएगा कि उस
उस डाउट का डाउट था तो क्या था था तो अभी
मैं बताता हूं कि उसे समझ में आ जाएगा तो
वो कौन-कौन से एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल होते
प्री डिफाइंड वेबल क्लियर कर देता हूं एक
बार आपको सबसे पहले जो एक सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल होता है सबसे पहले हम जब एकको
करते हैं और डॉलर डॉलर होम डॉलर होम अब एक
चीज और बताता हूं कि हम नॉर्मली क्या करते
हैं कि वेरिएबल को कैसे भी डिफाइन कर सकते
हैं बस बेसिकली क्या है एज प्रोग्राम में
हमने क्या है कि एक मेंटालिटी बना रखी है
कि जो सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल है जो
सिस्टम्स में डिफाइन किए जाते हैं हम उनको
क्या है कैपिटल में डिफाइन करते हैं ऑल
कैपिटल और जो हम यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल
उनको हम क्या स्मल में स्मल में क्या करते
हैं डिफाइन करते हैं सो दैट की जो
डिफरेंशियल वेरिएबल एंड द य डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल उनमें क्या है
डिफरेंशिएबल तो इसलिए क्या किया डॉलर होम
क्या कैपिटल में दिखाई दे रहा है ये एक
सिस्टम डिफ अब ये करता क्या है मैंने एकको
किया यहां पर आपको क्या देखने को मिला है
होम और काली होम और काली मतलब डॉलर होम के
अंदर क्या है कि जो यूजर्स है करेंटली
प्रेजेंटली जिस यूजर से मैं लॉगिन किया
हुआ हूं उस यूजर्स की होम डायरेक्टरी को
शो करता है वो भी उसका फुल एब्सलूट पाथ के
साथ फुल एब्सलूट पाथ के साथ अगर आपको ये
नहीं पता एब्सलूट पाथ और रिलेटिव पाथ क्या
होते हैं तो प्लीज जाइए हमारी प्लेलिस्ट
में कास की प्लेलिस्ट में वहां पर आपको
बहुत बेहतरीन कंटेंट दिया हुआ है रिसेंटली
हम मैंने एक कमेंट देखा है किसी स्टूडेंट
ने किया कि लिनक्स के एडमिन के व इंटरव्यू
में देने के लिए गया था मेरे कोर्स 15
वीडियोस काफी हेल्पफुल आए उसके कुछ
क्वेश्चंस थे जो उससे रिलेटेड पूछे ग तो
काफी डिटेल में वो आसानी से बता पाया और
एक्सप्लेन कर पाया आप अगर वोह चाहो तो
कमेंट देख सकते हो हमने वह कमेंट नहीं
करवाया है अग हम तो किसी से जबरदस्त कोई
भी कमेंट नहीं करवाते स्टडेंट अपने दिल से
कमेंट करते हैं
तो आपको समझ में आया कि एकको डॉलर होम
क्या करता है जिस भी यूजर से आप क्या है
करेंटली लगड हो उसी यूजर को क्या करता है
य एब्सलूट पाथ के साथ उसके होम डायरेक्टरी
को रिप्रेजेंट करता है आउटपुट में एक और
होता है
एकको डॉलर होम एक डॉलर डॉलर यूजर यूएस
डॉलर यूजर टर कर यह क्या करता है आपका कि
भी मशीन से आप लगन कि हु उसके यूजर नेम को
आपके स्क्रीन के सामने प्रिंट करता
हैप काली से किया अगर मैं स्विच सड करता
हूं स्विच करता हूं और मैं रूट बन जाता
हूं मैं रूट बन जाता हूं एंटर किया अब मैं
क्या करता करता हूं और डॉलर करता हूं और
यूजर य सिंपल य अब य रूट शो करेगा आ आपको
समझ में आ गया से बाहर आ जाता एक और होता
है
को डॉलर होस्ट
नेम होस्ट नेम एक और होता है यह क्या
बताता है आपकी मशीन के या पीसी जो नाम है
उसको शो करता है जो करंट पीसी है पीसी है
उसके नाम को शो खाली है यह खाली इसलिए है
क्योंकि यह डिफाइन किया हुआ नहीं है जब तक
इसको डिफाइन नहीं करें इसकी वैल्यू को यह
एमटी ही शो करेगा यह आपकी क्या करता है य
होस्ट होस्ट क्या होती है आपकी मशीन आपकी
मशीन है जो करंट मशीन है उसके नाम को शो
करता है आउटपुट में ये जनरली आपको खाली ही
मिलेगा एक और होता है
एकको एकको डॉलर होस्ट टाइप होस्ट
टाइप यह रहा होस्ट टाइप यह भी आपको क्या
खाली देखने को मिल रहा है अर बाकी कई बार
ये यहां पर जो वैल्यू आती है व आती है
आपके प्रोसेसर की आर्किटेक्चर
वैल्यू आपके जो प्रोसेसर है उसका
आर्किटेक्चर क्या है उसकी वैल्यू यहां पर
शो करता है बट मेरी मशीन में खाली है एक
और होता है आपका एक डॉलर
सेल अब ये आपको रिप्रेजेंट कर रहा है कि
करेंटली जो मेरी मशीन है वो कौन से सेल को
यूज कर रही है कौन से सेल को यूज कर र स्ल
यूजर स्ल बन बस ज ज सेल को ये यूज कर रही
है अगर मैं क्या करता इसको बेस्ट सेल यूज
करूंगा तो भी यह उसको शो करेगा स्ल यूजर
स्ल बन बस ओके ये शो करेगा अब बात करते
हैं एक और वेरिएबल हो एकको
डॉलर पीडब्ल्यूडी एकको डॉलर पीडब्ल्यूडी
ये आपको शो करता है प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
आप प्रेजेंटली किस डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
में है ओके आई होप मुझे लगता कि आज काफी
टाइम हो गया कांसेप्ट आपका काफी बचा हुआ
है तो हम क्या करते हैं कि कंटिन्यू नहीं
करेंगे क्योंकि जितना मैंने आप को प्रॉमिस
किया है कि जो डिलीवरी करूंगा वह आपकी मैं
35 टू 40 मिनट ही करूंगा तो क्योंकि आप
लोग बोलते शॉर्ट वीडियो चाहिए तो इसलिए न
इ हम शॉर्ट वीडियो करेंगे कुछ और सिस्टम
डिफाइंड वेरिएबल बचे हुए हैं उनके बारे
में कंटिन्यू ने नेक्स्ट क्लास से हम
डिस्कस करेंगे कंटिन्यू
और उसके बाद क्या है कुछ और चीजें बताऊंगा
मैं जो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है तो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन आपका कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ आपका जो
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है वो कंप्लीट नहीं
हुआ तो नेक्स्ट क्लास और लगे आपके
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन कंप्लीट होने में तो
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन में क्या है बेसिकली
कुछ एडवांस फीचर्स होते हैं जो हम उसके
नेक्स्ट क्लास में डिस्कस करेंगे तो आज का
सेशन यहीं पर एंड करते हैं तो जितने लोग
हैं प्लीज अगर किसी को यहां तक कुछ समझ
में नहीं आया तो उनके लिए 5 मिनट डाउट
सेशन है तो कांसेप्ट से रिलेटेड कोई भी आप
डाउट यहां पर पूछ सकते हैं नो इशू सेशन इ
नाउ इट्स ओपन फॉर
डाउट अगर सबको सब कुछ क्लियर है तो भी बता
दए अब किसी को डाउट है तो पूछ सकता है मैं
चैट सेशन में आपकी चैट देख रहा हूं पढ़
रहा हूं आपके डाउट में क्लियर करूंगा इधर
अभी सेशन में एक घंटे लेकर जाता हूं कि फ
बाद में बोलते कि सर लंग सेशन होते हैं
शर्ट सेशन काफी अच्छे रहते हैं तो ओके अ
मैं शर्ट सेशन ही आपके लेने वाला हूं तो
इसीलिए मैंने 35 टू 40 मिनट का ही जो
डिलीवरी है मेरी वही मैं आपके सामने
रखूंगा अगर सेशन बीच में अगर छूटता भी है
अगर कांसेप्ट थोड़ा सा रहता तो कोई बात
नहीं हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे नेक्स्ट सेशन
से बता दीजिए यार जितने भी लाइव
हो यस नो बोल सकते
हो
इट ओके मुझे लगता है किसी को कोई डाउट
नहीं है तो कोई बताने वाला नहीं है इट्स
ओके नो प्रॉब्लम तो नेक्स्ट सेशन में
करेंगे तो अगेन आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है
अगर आप लोगों को मेरी वीडियो अच्छी लगी हो
मेरा कंटेंट री आप लोग पसंद आ रहा हो तो
प्लीज डोंट फॉरगेट टू लाइक एंड
सब्सक्राइब और फदर अगर आपको नए नए
नोटिफिकेशन चाहिए तो हमें सब्सक्राइब
कीजिए
और हमें सब्सक्राइब कीजिए और क्या आपको
क्या करना है बेल नोटिफिकेशन को ऑन कीजिए
और आपको एक काम और कीजिए कि आप लोग जिसके
पास भी लिंकन प्रोफाइल नहीं है तो लिंकन
प्रोफाइल बना लीजिए क्योंकि लिंकन पर ही
सारी चीजें हैंडल होती है फदर लिंकन प ही
आपको आपके लिंक क्रिएट होते हैं तो हमारे
लिंकन चैनल पर क्या है कि डेनिक्स का पेज
है उधर जाइए लिंकन पर और सर्च कीजिए
डेनिक्स डेनिक्स जैसे ही सर्च करोगे वहां
पर हमारा क्या है प्रोफाइल पेज आ जाएगा तो
वहां पर क्या है डेली बेसिस पर जो भी हम
कोर्स कंटेंट डिलीवरी करते हैं वो हम वहां
पर पोस्ट करते हैं तो वहां पर क्या करना
आपको जाना है लाइक करना है कमेंट करना है
अच्छा लगा बुरा लगा ताकि अगर आप आपको लगता
है कि ये कंटेंट सही नहीं है तो उधर ही
बताइए सो ट की किसी का बुरा ना हो और किसी
का अगर आप चाहते हो अच्छा हो और यह आगे और
बाकी लोगों को सीखने को मिले अगर आप चाहते
हो तो प्लीज जाइए कमेंट में बताइए आपने
क्या सीखा है क्या नहीं सीखा और हम क्या
करते हैं कि
वह आपको क्या करते हैं कि हम उधर आपको
नोट्स भी प्रोवाइड करते हैं मैंने क्या
रोड मैप टाइप का उर इसका ब प्रोसेस कमांड
लाइन इसके बारे में रोड मैप आपको क्या
किया है उधर बताया हुआ है आप चाहो तो व
पिक्चर्स देख सकते हो तो उस पिक्चर के
हिसाब से हम चल रहे हैं अभी और जल्दी
सुना मैं करवा रहा हूं उसके मैं आपको
मोस्ट पबबली आपको पीडीएफ भी अवेलेबल करवा
दूंगा जैसे ही मुझे टाइम मिलेगा वो
कंप्लीट हो जाएगी साथ के साथ में आप लोगों
के लिए वो भी राइटिंग आईम ट्राई माय बेस्ट
बट डोंट वरी वो हम आपको प्रोवाइड कर देंगे
टाइम लग सकता है बट प्रोवाइड कर देंगे और
एक और चीज जितने भी नए लोग हैं या जो
फर्स्ट टाइम आज देखने वाले और आज के बाद
देखने वाले हैं आप लोगों के लिए गुड न्यूज
य है कि हमने अपनी एड पप लंच कर दी है
डेनिक्स के नाम से तो तो वहां पर आपको
क्या करना है प्ले स्टोर पर जाना है डेनिक
सर्च करना है और अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं तो
अभी मोबाइल तो नहीं है मोबाइल लेकिन आप
जैसे ही सर्च करोगे
डेनिक्स रा ऑन प्ले स्टोर मैं आपको दिखा
रहा हूं प्ले स्टोर पर जाओगे तो यह वाला
लोगो आपको देखने को मिलेगा जो ये रहा सेम
लोगो आपको प्ले स्टोर पर देखने को मिलेगा
तो जाइए हमारी प को इंस्टॉल कीजिए और वहां
पर क्या है कि फरदर आपके जो भी है
ट्रेनर्स है या इवन एडमिन है सभी सभी वहां
पर क्या लाइव क्लासेस कुछ फ्री लाइव
क्लासेस लेते हैं और जितने भी कोर्सेस है
सब कुछ है फर्द आपको वहीं पर नोटिफिकेशन
मिलेंगे वहीं से आपको क्या है कि पेड
कोर्सेस की जो बात कर रहे हैं तो वहीं पर
आपको जवाइन करने को मिलेंगे वहां पर बहुत
ही सस्ते कोर्सेस आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
आने वाले टाइम में काफी कोस्ट इफेक्टिव
रहेंगे आसानी आपको नहीं कोर्स लेने से
पहले सोचना नहीं पड़ेगा इधर डायरेक्टली आप
हमारी प से ही कोर्स को जवाइन कर पाओगे
लाइव देख पाओगे चा उधर ही डाउनलोड कर
पाओगे ऑफलाइन न बाद में देख पाओगे काफी
इंटरफेस काफी शानदार बनाया है डेवलपर ने
तो मुझे लगता है कि आप लोग उसको यूटिलाइज
करना चाहिए तो थैंक यू फॉर दैट कमिंग फॉर
सेशन तो सेशन यही पर एंड करते हैं थैंक यू
बाय बाय गुड डे टेक केर सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन